America's cigar industry which is
vibrant and impressive could be on the
brink of collapse why because of
holdover regulations from the Obama
administration until 2016 cigars were
unregulated in this country and worked
fine but then the FDA suddenly declared
that it had the power to regulate them
somehow and so they've come up with new
regulations banning cigar giveaways
imposing new fees on companies and
requiring extensive FDA testing before
companies released new cigars the FDA
admits these regulations will destroy
companies in jobs but they say it
doesn't matter because there are lots of
jobs in America for real you can read it
they say that rocky patel is the owner
of Rocky Patel premium cigars she's one
of the most probably the most famous
cigar maker in this country and he joins
us so ain't rocky thanks for coming on
thanks tucker I missed it did someone
vote for this did voters say they wanted
this absolutely not you know in fact you
know Congress never intended police cars
to be regulated they only intended
smokeless and cigarettes to be regulated
so the FDA took it upon themselves to
decide to one one glove fits all size
and start regulating the premium cigar
industry they didn't take the
opportunity to investigate and
understand the nature of the premium
cigar industry basically it's family
owned businesses that have been making
cigars over decades the retailers are
Main Street mom-and-pop industries that
are selling premium cigars to adults you
know the average cigar smoker smokes one
cigar per month the twenty four point
five years old the cigars are marketed
in luxury lifestyle magazines like cigar
aficionado next to premium cars watches
fine spirits they're literally enjoyed
like a single malt glass of scotch or
fine bottle of wine so it's very
different you certainly don't see kids
sitting around the schoolyard or outside
the schoolyard chain smoking cigars of
course so there are 11 bucks for their
using the Joule they're smoking
marijuana nobody seems to care by the
way but now they're basically gonna
crush your industry to help who
absolutely it's ridiculous they haven't
really taken the time to understand the
nature of our industry there's a cottage
industry it's an artisan industry it's
very very unique you know it takes us
four to five years to make a premium
cigar by the time we plant a ceiling in
the ground
time you got a cigar in a box 300
different hands touches the tobacco
we're very proud like a like a fine wine
maker about the quality and the
craftsmanship about how we make a cigar
and these rules are so outrageous
there's sober demson they're impossible
to comply with it's basically de-facto
prohibition you started your company by
yourself you're an immigrant you're a
lawyer you came to this country you'd
like how many employees when you started
that's correct we started 3 3 3
employees out of how many yes basically
well about 2,500 to 3,500 employees
directly or indirectly
that's unbelievable so what I mean the
terrifying thing finally about this is
it doesn't seem like there's much you
can do what do you do if you're a
business and you learn that some
regulation has been written by an
unelected bureaucrat that's going to
destroy you you know it's crazy because
it's gonna wipe out 70% of these
family-owned manufacturing factories and
companies that have been created and
descended over generations about 50% of
these mom-and-pop retail stores in
mainstream America are going to be
jobless and out of out of business
because we can't introduce new products
to them the cost of constituent testing
chemical testing they don't even have
machines for things like that trumpet
warning stickers that that go on our
beautiful boxes that are you know that
that that have our vintages and that
tell our family's story and tell our
history all that is taken away from us
so these laws are made in such a manner
you know the it's regs like that you
just can't comply so but the Obama
people were almost at a time the Obama
people did this absolutely these young
people didn't why is it still did you
know I bet you I bet you that the Trump
Organization and people at the White
House aren't even aware of what's going
on with this regulation so this all
happened during the Obama regime this
was all passed through and you know
presently we have a couple bills pending
on both sides of the aisle we're trying
to get this omnibus bill presently to
get our language attached to exempt
premium cigars from this regulation we
have a lawsuit filed but you know we're
hoping that the Trump agenda the Trump
administration is aware of what's going
to happen to in the entire industry that
is going to be tens and tens of
thousands of jobs and about 500,000 jobs
in Central America
affect some immigration right exactly
rocky works out we're rooting for you
this is senseless and thank you for
fighting back good to see you thank you